[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نشكر كل الجماهير يعني اللي تواجده في
الملعب الجماهير الايرانيه الجماهير
القطريه الجماهير العربيه الكل اللي سانده
فلسطين وهذا التضامن الكبير مع الشعب
الفلسطيني القضيه الفلسطينيه يعني نشكرهم
من جديد وان شاء الله يعني ه التشجيع هذا
يتواصل في المباريات الجايه مهم جدا
بالنسبه لنا وبش نكون يعني حضورنا احسن
ونحقق هدفنا ان شاء الله شكرا هي السبورت
تبع كل اللي في الملعب وخارج الملعب سبورت
القضيه الفلسطينيه هذا بيدينا دافع احنا
كلاعبين لكن للاسف في اخطاء الفنيه في
الملعب هي سببت بالهزيمه ما تشتتنا له
الامور بالعكس ها الامور بدعمنا وتشجعنا
وتقوينا عشان ندي كل ما عننا بس ان شاء
الله نصلح اخطائنا في المباراه الجايه
للفوز